PHOENIX, GREAT PLAYERS, GREAT
COACH IN MONTY WILLIAMS, GREAT
ORGANIZATION.
BUT THESE PLAYERS, THEY'RE
CHAMPIONS EVERY DAY.
EVERY DAY THEY COME TO THE
BUILDING THEY ARE CHAMPIONS.
THEY'VE EMBRACED GETTING BETTER
EVERY DAY, EMBRACED COMPETING
AND PLAYING TOGETHER.
IT'S MADE THEM CHAMPIONS
TONIGHT.
I COULDN'T BE HAPPIER.
SO HAPPY FOR THESE PLAYERS.
>> BUD, IT ISN'T EVERY DAY THE
COACH GETS A CHANCE TO WORK WITH
A TWO-TIME MVP.
WHAT HAS BEING WITH GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO EVERY DAY FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS, HOW HAS THAT
SHAPED YOU?
>> I'M BLESSED TO WORK WITH
GIANNIS EVERY DAY.
HE'S AN AMAZING HUMAN BEING.
HE'S EVEN MORE AMAZING AS A
HUMAN THAN A PLAYER.
I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH IN HIM.
HIS LEADERSHIP, CHRIS'
LEADERSHIP.
I'M SO GLAD TO BE A PART OF
THIS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU, CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CROWD CHANTING "MVP" ]
>> THAT'S RIGHT, MVP.
NOW FOR THE PRESENTATION OF THE
2021 BILL RUSSELL FINALS MVP
AWARD, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING BACK COMMISSIONER
SILVER.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S MUCH
DOUBT.
HE PLAYED THROUGH ADVERSITY,
PLAYED THROUGH INJURY.
NO DOUBT GIVEN HE WAS THE
TWO-TIME MVP IN THE LEAGUE, THIS
YEAR BILL RUSSELLS FINAL MVP,
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ CROWD CHANTING "MVP" ]
>> GIANNIS, WHEN YOU RE-SIGNED
HERE, YOU SAID THAT YOU WANTED
TO BE A PART OF BUILDING A
CHAMPIONSHIP CULTURE IN
MILWAUKEE FOR YEARS TO COME.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU TO MAKE
GOOD ON THAT COMMITMENT IN THE
CITY THAT DRAFTED YOU?
>> IT MEANS A LOT.
I WANT TO THANK MILWAUKEE FOR
BELIEVING IN ME, THANK MY
TEAMMATES.
THEY PLAYED HARD EVERY FREAKING
GAME.
I TRUSTED THIS TEAM.
I WANTED TO DO IT HERE IN THIS
CITY, WITH THESE GUYS, SO I'M
HAPPY.
I'M HAPPY WE WERE ABLE TO GET IT
DONE.
>> IT IS A RARITY, GIANNIS, TO
BE ABLE TO PLAY EIGHT YEARS WITH
A TEAMMATE, LET ALONE WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP TOGETHER IN THOSE
EIGHT YEARS.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE WHAT
KHRIS MIDDLETON MEANS TO YOU?
>> KHRIS, WE DID IT, HUH?
YOU KNOW, I'M HAPPY.
I'M HAPPY, MAN.
THIS GUY DOESN'T REALLY KNOW HOW
MUCH HE PUSHED ME.
PUSHED ME EVERY DAY TO BE GREAT.
EVERY DAY TO BE GREAT, MAN, AND
I'M HAPPY I CAN STEP ON THE
FLOOR WITH THIS GUY AND PLAY
EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH THIS GUY,
AND THE OTHER GUYS BUT KHRIS IS
SPECIAL.
WE HAVE BEEN TOGETHER EIGHT
YEARS.
I WAS HAPPY I WAS ABLE TO DO IT
WITH HIM AND WITH MILWAUKEE.
WHAT DID COACH BUD SAY?
WE HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN.
>> I THINK THEY LIKE THAT.
GIANNIS, YOU'VE NEVER BEEN SHY
THAT FAMILY IS AT THE CORE OF
EVERYTHING YOU DO, AND NOW TWO
OF YOUR BROTHERS ARE NBA
CHAMPIONS.
>> WHOO!
I'M JUST HAPPY.
I'M HAPPY THAT, YOU KNOW, A LOT
OF PEOPLE IS MAKING JOKES LAST
YEAR.
WHEN